hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu grand theft taxi das ist
ein spiel wird sich im internet gefunden
habe was mit einem taxi es wir sind hier
schon im menü haben wir die controls das
ziel ist geld ist nicht einfach mal auf
play und werden glaube ich schon direkt
reingeschmissen und die sache ist wie
wenn wir irgendwo gegen faden hast dir
das hier
wir verlieren geld und es explodiert
unten rechts ist das wollte ich nicht
man das ist unglaublich schwierig mein
gott ich kann sogar es kann man da
pocking driften man die pfeile zeigen
mir da hin wo ich kunden abholen muss
beispielsweise vorne hier genau das hab
ich den kunden eingesammelt und dem muss
ich jetzt dahin bringt wo der grüne
pfeil wieder hin zeigt und 20 minuten
zehn sekunden und bekomme ich kein geld
und ich habe jetzt 148 bekommen wir
vorne haben die auch schon in den
nächsten kunden taxi benötigt und er
muss nämlich jetzt hier vorne hin oh
mein gott es tut mir leid
drei sekunden eine und verehrt ich bin
super taxifahrer ich schon dunkel
ich habe jetzt die nächsten konnten und
er muss dahin gehen das ist ein
hersteller wäre ende wir haben hier
hinten noch einen
das war jetzt das ende willkommen zu tag
nummer 2 in dieser tolle ich habe schon
wieder eine ampel und noch ein auto
alles klar die steuerung ist echt so
behindert ich hab das spiel nur bei game
gold gesehen und dafür so jo vielleicht
kann die scheiß ja was jetzt man schon
wieder ein fall darf man so jung
vielleicht kann das game was es ist
eigentlich ganz nett animiert ich mag
solche grafiken immer ganz gern das
ganze wird im zuge von irgend so ein
game developer challenge oder sonnen
ship gemein zu mir leid war so ein game
developer challenge wo leute innerhalb
von 48 stunden ein game kreieren muskel
und da hat dieses entwicklerstudio
dieses spiel hier auf die beine gestellt
und dafür dass es in zwei tagen gemacht
wurde ist es eigentlich ultra das alter
das kann doch echt nicht sein wieso
stehen denn so viele autos wie soll ich
denn hier du natürlich explodiert ihr
alle wieder wie soll ich denn durch
diese scheiß automation hier durchkommen
wenn wir ein verdammter verkehr ist
alter schon wieder meine das spiel kann
noch so nice 1 von der grafik und alle
möglichen aber es muss doch irgendwie so
zahlen dass man komme ich als game over
ich liebe dieses spiel ich dachte wie
grand theft taxi so vielleicht muss ich
auch aussteigen und die leute irgendwie
dann mit reinholen und jetzt steht der
bus da im weg ich werd ichs sache und
ich werde jetzt geld kassieren für
diesen scheiß kunden es ist mir komplett
egal wo es hilfe und wie viele leute
dafür töten muss aber ich werde dieses
spiel ist so fucking schwermann es ist
einfach nicht möglich das ganze schaffen
ohne dass man die halbe matt
auseinandernimmt so kommen jetzt dahin
ist das ziel oder wo ist denn das niveau
muss ich denn hin und wieder rast das
ziel um dort vielleicht hab ich
geschafft vielleicht schaff es ist auch
einfach überhaupt nicht möglich zu
driften alter es ist einfach nicht es
geht einfach nicht man das spiel kann
noch so esse ich schon wieder game over
stellen sich die entwickler das denn vor
irgendwie hier die leute wie
wie soll man es denn schaffen es ist
unmöglich bei sonnen verkehr innerhalb
von zehn sekunden
das geht nicht man ich schwöre euch
google grand theft taxi und sagt mir ob
es möglich ist weil das ist es nicht das
sieht nach einem ultra guten mann aus
freunde soll hier schon um die kurve rum
und jetzt hier links und jetzt es geht
nicht dann holen wir jetzt hier vorne
stellen noch einen kunden ab drehen hier
ganz schnell mit dem you turn so drehen
jetzt fahren sie dann die andere
richtung weil ich habe gerade erst
erfahren dass ich ihn da hinten
abstellen dann ist auf einmal genau wahr
wir nehmen hier das taxi mit ich zeig
euch jetzt ich mache jetzt so schnell es
geht so ich habe versucht den usern zu
machen da war allerdings der baum im weg
jetzt gucke ich wo wir hinfahren müssen
machte hier schnell eine kurve hier
steine kurve so und jetzt lag es geht
nicht freunde ein kompletter ran wir
haben hier das taxi wir fahren hier um
die kurve und versuchen ihn hier hinten
abzuliefern das müssten wir diesmal
schaffen das müssen wir schaffen so da
haben wir 2 112 ab zudem fackeln ort
alter sagt es kann doch nicht so schwer
sein eintrag vorne das finish
wir nehmen das taxi mit rasen so schnell
es geht irgendwie zu dem ort hier hätten
um ein gott ist kann nicht wahr sein
ich schiebe so einen hass auf dieses
spiel ein paar sekunden später die tk
game jam games as crashed and workflows
fatal error
meine damen und herren ich möchte dieses
video leider beenden weil das spiel
gecrasht es wenn euch das ganze trotzdem
gefallen hat und ich denke ich kann das
besser dann googelt einfach fucking run
fat tax mein gott es ist einfach nicht
möglich zum abschied noch mal eine tolle
sprache ich die migranten kumpel
geschickt hat
ich habe gefolgt keine alles geld